hello everyone and welcome back to round
three of the tata still 2021
now with the last game we'll be showing
the leader of the tournament nils axel
grendelius
versus pentala hari krishna it's quite
the game and it features everyone's
favorite opening so let's see
how the game went uh niels opens with e4
and harry krishna goes for e6 the french
defense
we have d4 d5 and now e5
uh grendelius goes for the advanced
variation of the french with c5 striking
in the center
and now c3 and here queen to b6
uh putting more pressure on that central
central d4 pawn with knight to f3
developing and defending
and now bishop to d7 the bishop is now
coming
to b5 and the black wants to already
trade white's a
very strong light square bishop and in a
lot of lines this bishop
poses a lot of problems for black so
here bishop to e2
and now a trade in the center c capture
c captures and bishop to b5
now trades uh trades off the slide
square bishop and it's not a very
i mean it has been played before but
it's not a line that i've seen
anywhere i think and i really like it
for black so
it might give you some ideas if you're
also a french player
uh we have castles uh and now black just
exchanges this light square bishop
captures captures and now
knight to c6 continues developing and
it's um
it seems like a very nice idea as black
kind of sets the
the tone of the battle here so knights
to c3 white continues developing
uh and here it seems like white is
offering the d4 pawn but this pawn is
not to be captured it's uh well it's
extremely
poisoned uh because if captures captures
and captures then black is already lost
just queen b5 check and not much you can
do here you're gonna capture the spawn
threaten the rook after you do this you
can play
whatever bishop to e3 rook to d1 uh and
there's just uh well nothing good uh for
for the black queen for example if you
capture on e5 just knight captures on d5
and black's entire position falls apart
of course if you capture you even lose
the queen
and it's just game over so of course
this pawn
is not free for grabs we have knight g
to e7
and now queen to d3 improving the the
activity of this white queen
also adds now a second defender to the
d4 pawn interestingly last time this
position has been reached
it was some 21 years ago uh and here
rook the c8 which is a new move
so it is uh pentala hari krishna who
first brings us
a new position on the board so already
as of movie 11 a completely new game
uh we have rook to d1 developing and
adding another defender to the d-pawn
and now
h6 take away taking away the g5 square
from the
from the white knight also at some point
black will castle and you want to have
some
breeding room for the king bishop to d2
and now knight to g6 uh we have h4 by
white white of course wants to push
h5 all the way and then push the black
knight back to it where it came from
with bishop
to b4 by hari krishna and now
knight the a4 with an attack on the
queen offering a trait of dark square
bishops and here we have queen back to
c7
and even h5 so pushing that knight back
with
knight back to e7 and now bishop to f4
and this is the first interesting move
of the game
uh here you can just continue developing
rook a to c1 which uh
definitely makes sense but for some
reason grandelus wanted to keep the dark
square bishops on the board
and well we'll just see what happens
with this we have queen to a5 now
attacking the knight here b3 defending
and now b5
kicking the knight back knights to b2
and now even bishop to a3 forcing white
to decide how the knight will be
defended
the knight has no squares uh where it
can go to so the knight
you have to defend the knight so queen
e2 again guarding the knight and now the
queen again
leaves this uh excellent d3 square goes
back to e2 to where
she came from we have castles by uh hari
krishna and
now rook 8 to b1 defending the knight
but also now you freed the square so
you can bring the knight into the game
this way rook the c7
black has some ideas of maybe doubling
up here on the c file and now
knight to d3 uh we have queen back to b6
uh making room for that pawn to be
pushed and now
b4 and here with this b4 uh you're
threatening rook to b3 so d4 pawn is
again not free for grabs if you go after
it captures captures and captures
uh you're just losing the bishop here
first you can harass the queen
let's say bishop to e3 and after the
queen moves queen e4
f3 even queen to h4 and now rook b3 you
just pick up the bishop there's
nothing black can do to stop this so
after b4 we have
a5 now ready to meet rook b3 with just
uh
captures the b4 pawn is attacked twice
so captures captures and
now again we have this very very uh well
crucial moment uh where white needs to
decide what to do here it's it's a very
a tricky position to play and one thing
white might consider is this g4 idea
taking away the f
uh f5 square from uh black snide but
here
white played bishop to c1 and it's a
really really
weird maneuver first the bishop was on
d2 offering a trade here then uh
grindelways decided not to trade it then
he brought it back to f4
uh and then back to c1 and now uh okay
uh we have bishop captures on c1 rook
captures with uh sorry
uh rook d captures on c1 rook captures
on c1
and now knight captures on c1 uh hoping
to get to that knight
to some active square uh but now knight
the c4 and you can see how
uh black is the one who's uh again
dictating the tone of the battle
as white doesn't really have all that
all that many active plants and black
wants to bring the rook to
it black wants to bring the rook to a3
put more pressure on white
and white uh seems just have to wait and
see what black will do so here
knight to b3 and rook to a8 as planned
with
rook to c1 and now knight
the c6 bringing another knight into the
game the knight is now coming to b4
and with the two knights on the fourth
rank all of these squares will be
covered
so g3 making room on g2 for the king and
now
rook to a3 and now you're preparing
queen to a7 to put more pressure on the
a2 pawn
king to g2 and now queen to a7
uh we rook to c2 defending the a2 pawn
twice but now
knight to b4 and all of a sudden uh
white
is uh white is dead lost uh you're gonna
lose the a2 pawn
black's gonna be left with a past b pawn
and it seems like
this game uh was just uh you know
straight out of a
victory for black uh out of nowhere
which is something that often
uh often happens when you play against
the french so rook the c3
uh defending but not just knight
captures on a2 we rook to d3
and here uh hari krishna goes for the
absolute quickest way to end the game
uh he just plays rook captures on b3
gives up the exchange
only temporary uh because after captures
he has a nice fork here
knight to c1 forking the queen and the
rook uh queen to c2 and now just
captures we have captures and queen to
a4
of course the queen trade cannot uh
cannot happen because then
you just push the a pawn to victory so
of course the grendel just had to move
the queen queen to b1 but not just b4
and it was in this position that uh
niels grendelus
resigned in the game as there is nothing
more to be done here a wonderful victory
for pentala
krishna who is now on two out of three
in only 38 moves so here you resign
because black's plan is very simple you
want to push the pawn to b2 and play
queen a1
there's nothing white can do to stop
this if you try something like knight to
e1 to
bring it into the game b3 knight to d3
and now
queen to a2 uh just to give me a second
uh queen to a2 uh and now uh
of course white cannot trade white has
to move queen to d1
uh and now it's all over for example
knight e3 check uh
forks the king and the queen and even if
you don't run into this fork whatever
you play queen c1 is just a matter of
time b2 the queen has to move and then
you get another queen intro game
or you just have to give up material
here captures captures oh sorry
wrong capture captures captures and
captures and then
it's just a completely winning end game
for black black now has a knight why
doesn't and of course completely winning
so really interesting stuff and uh we
always enjoy seeing uh
the french defense played on the highest
level because you never know what will
happen here uh
yani palmish used it with success in in
the candidates tournament
uh last year uh and uh well it is
just a a fine opening if you know your
way around it and for those of you
who are new to chess uh you might not
have seen uh bobby fischer's game
against kovacho which were kovacs which
employed
the french defense against bobby fischer
himself so i will put a link to that
in the description below it will be the
first thing you see so if you want to
check that out as well
uh but yeah uh we a very nice victory
for hare krishna and we said that we
were going to show the standings now
after the the three rounds have passed
so these are the standings
uh with two points we have uh pentala
hari krishna magnus carlsen anish geary
fabiano corona and niels grandelius
with one and a half points uh jordan von
forrest uh
maxim vashila grab
end with half a point out of three
alexander donchenko
so we'll see what happens still very
early on in the game
in the tournament so anything can still
happen uh so
uh i would like to thank uh divi dynamo
uh seattle and farah
louis matheson uh omar dasa and ryan
urban for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the tata
still checking up on your wonderful
suggestions
uh and whatever else happens in the
chess world uh so thank you all i will
see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day